[موسيقى]
مساء الخير هذه اخبار الساعه
جورنال عن تقرير حكومي واشنطن ترك
الطائرات وصواريخها ومعدات بقيمه سبعه
مليار دولار بيد طالبان
اوكرانيا تتوقع تصعيدا عسكريا خلال الاشهر
الثلاثه المقبله لحسم الحرب والكرم لن
يؤكد ان الحل السلمي ليس الان
[تصفيق]
تحذيرات غربيه من تفجر الوضع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واصطاد لجميع الاطراف للتهدئه
ترفض بشده تقارير الامريكيه بان فيروس
كورونا تسرب اثر حادث عربي في مختبر صيني
[موسيقى]
اداره بايدن بالتخلي عن المتعاقدين
الافغان
[موسيقى]
18 شهرا مرت على الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان
صعدت بعده مباشره حركه طالبان الى السلطه
مغيره المشهد السياسي بشكل جذري في البلد
الذي عان لسنوات
الانسحاب الامريكي فاجا الحكومه السابقه
في افغانستان وفق تقرير حكومي نشرته صحيفه
التقرير الذي جرى بطلب من الكونجرس
الامريكي والذي سيناقشه قريبا اتهم
البنتاجون بعدم التعاون مع التحقيق حول
انهيار الجيش الافغاني وانه لم يقدم الدعم
الامني للحكومه الافغانيه السابقه كما وعد
ضمن بنود الانسحاب مما سمح بانهيار الجيش
والحكومه وصعود طالبان الى السلطه خلال
ايام معدوده
كما اشار الى تقديم البنتاجون لاجابات غير
كامله على الاسئله لترد وزاره الدفاع
بدورها انها تعاونت مع التحقيق قائله انها
قدمت ردودا مكتوبه على اسئله المفتش العام
نقلا عن التقرير الامريكي القت باللوم على
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن التي لم
تلتزم باتفاق انسحاب القوات الامريكيه بين
طالبان واداره ترامب ما ادى لانتقادات بين
الحزبين الرئيسيين طالت الرئيس بايدن عدا
عن الاتهامات بسوء تخطيط الانسحاب وعدم
الاهتمام بحمايه المتعاقدين الافغان كما
كشفت المعلومات عن ترك الولايات المتحده
معدات عسكريه وراءها في افغانستان بقيمه
تزيد عن سبعه مليارات دولار بين الطائرات
وصواريخ واسلحه ومعدات اتصال
سبعه مليارات دولار من المعدات الصالحه
للعمل من اصل 18 مليارا انفقتها امريكا
على تسليح الجيش الافغاني الذي انهار في
ساعات معدوده
التقرير ختم باهميه عدم تكرار التجربه
الافغانيه في اوكرانيا منبها الى ضروره
مراقبه المساعدات العسكريه التي تقدمها
الولايات المتحده لكييف قائلا ان التورط
الامريكي في هذه الصراعات اظهر عدم القدره
على التعلم من الاخطاء
نعرف اكثر من مراسلنا في واشنطن اهلا بك
معنا سبعه مليارات من المعادلات العسكريه
خلفتها خلفها القوات الامريكيه في
افغانستان عقباء انسحابها ماذا نعرف عن
نوعيه هذه المعدات
العسكريون الامريكيون اكدوا اولا قبل ختم
الانسحاب من افغانستان انهم دمروا او
اخرجوا كل الاسلحه التي تعتبر مهمه من
ناحيه القياده والسيطره مثل السيارات او
غرف العمليات او ايضا حتى الطائرات من نوع
هليكوبتر او اشياء اخرى تعتبر متقدمه
تقنيا ما بقي في افغانستان هو اسلحه
كلاسيكيه بسيطه فرديه هي افضل لاستعمال
الشرطه من استعمال الجيوش هل تمكنت طالبان
من استخدام هذه المعدات او على الاقل جزء
منها حتى الان
بدون شك انها طالبه انها تمكنت من وضع
يدها على كميات هائله من الاسلحه ولكنها
ذخيره ومعدات فرديه وليست معدات متقدمه
وبالتالي ربما لا نرى خلال الاشهر المقبله
طائرات تطير في اجواء افغانستان على يد
الطيارين تابعين لطالبان وربما لن نرى
ايضا غرف عمليات متطوره تستطيع ان تقوم
بعمليات التحكم نعم ما دام الامر كذلك
والامريكيون يتحدثون عن تدمير المعدات
الثقيله التي لم يتمكنوا من اخذها معهم
اثناء الانسحاب هل هذا التقرير يستوجب رد
فعل امريكي فعل شيء ما في افغانستان ام هو
ضمن الصراع السياسي الحاصل
من غرائب العاصمه الامريكيه هو ان المفتش
الذي وضع هذا التقرير الطويل حول
افغانستان يختلف في تقييده
لمساعده
اخرى في الدوله الامريكيه مساعدتهم له في
وضع هذا التقرير وهناك وجهات نظر مختلفه
حول هذه القضيه اعضاء مجلس النواب
الامريكيه خصوصا الجمهوريون يستغلون هذا
الموضوع لانهم ما زالوا غاضبين من قرار
الرئيس بايدن بالخروج من افغانستان
وغاضبين اكثر من الطريقه التي خرجت فيها
القوات الامريكيه من افغانستان
قالت ان الكونجرس سيناقش ايضا هذه المساله
ومساله كذلك المتعاقدين الافغان ما
المنتظر من الكونجرس ما اقصى ما يمكن ان
يتخذه من قرار
يستطيع الجمهوريون ان يعبروا عن غضبهم
ولكن لا اعتقد ان ان هناك ايه خطوات عمليه
يستطيع الكونغرس اتخاذها في هذه
في هذا المجال ربما تكون المرحله السياسيه
في واشنطن تنذر بان على الامريكيين ان
يبذلوا جهودا اكبر للسيطره على المساعدات
التي يرسلونها الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي
يريدون مراقبه اكثر يريدون التاكد اكثر من
استعمال الاوكرانيين لهذه الاسلحه بطريقه
حكيمه من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن افغانستان اعتقلت قواته حرس
الحدود في طالبان عنصرا من افراد احرس
الحدود الايراني وذلك على معبر جسر الحرير
في ولايه نيمروزا الحدوديه جنوبي
افغانستان ذكرت مصادر ان قوات حاره الحدود
التابعه لطالبا اقتاده الجنديه الايراني
بعد اشتباكه مع السائق مركبه افغاني
[موسيقى]
زرت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جوني تيارن
كيف لتؤكد على دعم الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا
التقت بالرئيس زيلينسكي قائله الولايات
المتحده ستقف مع اوكرانيا ما دامت بحاجه
الدعم كما اعلنت عن تحويل 1.25 مليار
دولار من الحزمه البالغه 9.9 مليار دولار
كمساعدات من قبل واشنطن لاوكرانيا
هزه اخرى تضرب الجيش الاوكراني وهيئه
الدفاع مع اعلان الرئيس بلود اقاله قائد
عسكري كبير دون ابداء اسباب هذا القرار
الذي جاء بعد سلسله طويله من التغييرات في
قياده الجيش الاوكراني في الفتره الاخيره
بعضها مرتبط بملفات فساد
الجنرال ادوارد موسكاليف لواء في القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه شارك ميدانيا لصد
الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا قادم مجموعه
القوات العملياتيه والاستراتيجيه في
اوديسا النائب الاول لقائد قوات قياده
العمليات العسكريه شرق اوكرانيا تم تعيينه
قائدا للقوات المشتركه في الخامس عشر من
مارس لعام 2022
منحه الرئيس الاوكراني بسام بوجدان خامله
من الدرجه الثانيه اقاله الرئيس الاوكراني
من منصبه بموجب مرسوم رئاسي
وميدانيا تستمر المعارك الضاريه في الشرق
الاوكراني بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
مع تقدم طفيف لقوات باجنر التي تقاتل الى
جانب الجيش الروسي وفي اخر التطورات وبحسب
مصادر الروسيه تقاتل مجموعه فاجنر الان في
وسط باخموت بدونيتك واصبحت القوات الروسيه
تسيطر على جميع الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه
الى ذلك اشارت المصادر نفسها الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول تسليم المعدات
الى المدينه لكنها تتكبد خسائر فادحه اما
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ايغور
كوناشينكوم فدى بان السلاح الجوي الروسي
استهدف 88 وحده مدفعيه تابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مواقع اطلاق النار والقوى
العامله والمعدات في 173 منطقه خلال يوم
واحد كما اكد تدمير مركز الغرب للعمليات
الخاصه في اوكرانيا وفيما اعلنت المخابرات
الاوكرانيه ان الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله سوف
تشهد نشاطا عسكريا لحسم الحرب اكد المتحدث
باسم الكرملين ان العمليه العسكريه ستبقى
مستمره
نشر
طه
[موسيقى]
وفيما يخص العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا
جددت المجر تمسكها بموقفها الرافض تمديد
العقوبات الاوروبيه ضد روسيا مشدده على ان
هذا القرار لن يوقف النزاع الدائره في
اوكرانيا منذ اكثر من سنه بدوره راى وزير
الخارجيه بيتر سيارته ان فرضا عقوبات
اوروبيه جديده ضد روسيا لا يحدث او لن
يحدث فرقا مؤكدا ان ضخ الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
ايضا لا يوقف النزاع
نتابع منا كيف مع مراسلنا حذيفه علي
الحذيفه اهلا بك معنا بدايه هل هناك
المزيد من المواقف صدرت عن كيف بخصوص جهود
السلام وعلى راسها طبعا الخطه الصينيه
لاحلال السلام في اوكرانيا
مساء الخير صهيب هذه الصيغه او المبادره
الصينيه وجدت استحسان من بعض المسؤولين
ولكن ايضا وجدت انتقاد واسع من كثير من
المسؤولين وخاصه قياده الدوله على راسهم
الرئيس فلاديمير الذي تحدث بشكل ايجابي عن
هذه المبادره في بعض النقاط وانتقدها في
نقاط اخرى بشكل واضح قال ان هنالك نقاط
ايجابيه نتفق مع بكين فيها وعلينا العمل
عليها بشكل كبير مع بكين ولكن ايضا
للاستعاده وقال ان اي مبادره للسلام لا
تتضمن بند الانسحاب القوات الروسيه من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه فورا قبل البدء بعمليه
باي عمليه تفاوض هذه مبادره لا تعنينا
وغير مهمه بالنسبه لنا ايضا طبعا قائد
فصيل خادم الشعب
حزب الرئيس الذي انتقد بشده مبادره وايضا
انتقد موقف الصين في الامم المتحده
تصوت على صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه حذيفه هل
هناك اي معلومات اضافيه عن اسباب اقاله
قائد القوات المشتركه في الجيش الاوكراني
طبعا تمت اقالته بهدوء شديد هذا الرجل هو
يعني حاصل على وسام بغداد خميسك وهو وسام
رفيع في الدوله الاوكرانيه كذلك كان قائد
العمليات العسكريه لاوديسا وقائد الاركان
وايضا كذلك كان نائب قائد العمليات
القياده العملياتيه في الشرق التي تقاتل
منذ عام 2014 وحتى الان حيث الصراع في
الدوري وتم تعيينه بعد اقل من شهر من
بدايه الحرب وطول هذه الفتره كان في مصيبه
طبعا هنا لابد ان نشير الى انه ليس دائما
تكون الاقالات لاسباب يعني تقصير في
الخدمه او لاسباب فساد وما الى ذلك احيانا
بعض المسؤولين تتم اقالتهم لوضعهم في
مناصب اخرى وقد حدث ذلك في الفتره الماضيه
لعدد من المسؤولين ولكن لا يوجد اي تصريح
لا يوجد تعليق رسمي من الجهات الرسميه
خاصه من الجيش وكذلك الاعلام الاوكراني لم
يتناول الامر ولم يكن الامر باهتمام كبير
طبعا اللقاء تمت بالامس صهيب حذيفه عادل
من كيف
منح الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الممثله
الامريكيه ستيفن سيجال وسام الصداقه
الروسيه وتربط علاقه الصداقه بين بوتين
منذ فتره طويله
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يمنح الممثل
الامريكي ستيفن سيجال اسامه الصداقه
المعلومات الروسيه تقول ان الوسام بسبب
مساهمه سيجال في تطوير التعاون الثقافي
والانساني الدولي لكن لسجال علاقه بروسيا
وبوتين شخصيا قبل الوسام ومنذ فتره طويله
فسيجال المولود في ابريل عام
1952 بولايه ميشيغان الامريكيه يعد صديقا
مقربا جدا للرئيس الروسي ومدافعا قويا عن
سياساته كما حصل على الجنسيه الروسيه في
نوفمبر 2016 واستلم جوازه الروسي من بوتين
شخصيا رافق ايضا بوتين في عدد من فعاليات
الفنون الدفاع عن النفس
وفي عام 2018 عينت روسيا سيغال في منصب
ممثل وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الخاص لشؤون
الاتصالات الانسانيه مع امريكا اما بعد
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وخلال حفل عشاء
بموسكو وصف السيجال بوتين بزعيم العالم
الحر واخيرا توجت هذه الصداقه الغامضه بين
بوتين بنظر محللين بوسام صداقه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اردوغان يعتذر
لشعبه عن تاخر الاغاثه بعد زلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد على السفير الامريكيه في
اسرائيل مقتل مواطن امريكي بهجوم اليوم في
الضفه الغربيه وكانت اسرائيل قد اعلنت
مقتل مستوطنين في عمليه اطلاق نار في
اريحا وقال تسائل الاعلام ان اكثر من شخص
نفذوا الهجوم حيث اطلقوا الرصاصه في اكثر
من موقع في المنطقه قبل ان تفرض القوات
الاسرائيليه طوقا امنيا ولم تتمكن القوات
الاسرائيليه من ضبط منفذي الهجوم كما انها
اغلقت مداخل اريحا خلال المطارده
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو قال ان
حكومته ستقنن وضع المستوطنات التي ظلت غير
شرعيه لسنوات طويله نتنياهو اضافها ان
حكومته وستبني الاف المنازل في المستوطنات
كرد على الهجمات التي يتعرض لها
المستوطنون مشيرا الى انه لا يتم اقتلاع
الاسرائيليين من تلك المواقع على حد وصفه
من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
أفغالنت انه يتوقع اياما صعبه بعد احداث
العنف الاخيره
يتوقعوا اياما معقده وربما ايام الصعبه قد
يحدث هذا في الضفه الغربيه في القدس او في
غزه اعطيت تعليمات واضحه للجيش الاسرائيلي
وجهاز الامن العام وشرطه حرس الحدود
للاستعداد الكامل لمواجهه جميع التهديدات
من خلال زياده النشاط في الميدان واضافه
القوات والعناصر لحمايه المستوطنات والطرق
بدورهم اكد 22 خبيرا اسرائيليا في القانون
الدولي على ان افعالها المستوطنين في
الضفه الغربيه ترقى لجرائم حرب وفق صحيفه
المستوطنين على عده بلدات في الضفه اسفر
عن عشرات المصابين ليدعو الخبراء الى
تحقيق فوري في تلك الممارسات متهمين قاده
اقصى اليمين بالتحريض على العنف
ابدا منسق الامم المتحده الخاصه لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط
قلقه الشديد اذا اتدهور الاوضاع الامنيه
في الضفه الغربيه
على تويتر ان قوات الامن الاسرائيليه
تتحمل مسؤوليه الحفاظ على الامن ومنع
الافراد من تطبيق القانون بايديهم كما
اضاف المسؤول الامميه ان اعمال العنف
والاستفزازات والتحريض يجب ان تتوقف فورا
وان تتم ادانتها من جميع الاطراف بشكل
قاطع
رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيا كان دعا
لتفعيل لجان الحمايه الشعبيه للتصدي
للمستوطنين محملا تل ابيب المسؤوليه كامله
عن احداث بلده حوار
وهنا ادعو الى تفعيل عمل لجان الحمايه
الشعبيه في كل مكان وعلى ضوء الجرائم
البشعه التي ارتكبها المستعمرون الفاشيون
وبتوجيه من وزراء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فاننا نحمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل
المسؤوليه عن جرائم المستوطنين في حواره
وبقيه الكره المحيطه وسوف يضاف هذا
الاجرام الى ملف محاكمه اسرائيل في
المحاكم الدوليه وعليه فاننا سنقوم بتشكيل
لجنه وزاريه من وزاره الحكم المحلي
والماليه ومحافظ نابلس
للوقوف على الاضرار التي لحقت باهلنا هناك
لغرض المساهمه في تعويضهم
[موسيقى]
في الليل
هجموا مستوطنين انا كنت شايفهم لما حرقوا
السياره امي نزلت تحت معها مي رحت تطفي
السياره هسه في الجيش اجوا من هون احجم
المستوطنين وكسروها قعدنا نزلنا على الارض
فبعديها صرنا نسمع صوت من ورا الدار
بغرفتنا على الشبابيك رحت أفتح ولا هو في
ونزلت على الارض بعديها بالغرفه قاعده على
تلفوني وجارتنا بس جارتنا طلعت بس بس
مالكيناهم اللي هم بكسروا الدار فاحنا
بقينا بالغرفه ما توقعنا انهم يكسروا
الشباك علينا
وهربوهم عند الجيران
هاي اسمها سوار وهذا جوده
محرك المحل في الكامل والمنزل بقى فيه
اطفال
وكسروا كل البيت ما خلوا على اي شيء وغاز
بصي الدموع
نعرف اكتر من مراسلنا في رام الله عبد
الحفيظ جعوان عبد الحفيظ اهلا بك معنا
ابدا معك من اريحا كيف هو الوضع الان بعد
مقتل المستوطن الاسرائيلي
مدينه اريحا مغلقه بالكامل هناك حواجز على
مداخل المدينه من كل الجهات وهناك حشودات
عسكريه كبيره تجري عمليات دهم وتفتيش بحثا
عن منفذ او منفذي عمليه اطلاق النار كما
تقول وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان
عمليه اطلاق النار التي جرت مساء هذا
اليوم والتي ادت لمقتل مستوطن اسرائيلي
كانت متدحرجه عمليا هي مكونه من اربع
عمليات اطلاق نار
المنفذان قام باطلاق النار على سياره
اسرائيليه فقتلها مستوطن ثم اطلق النار
على سياره اخرى كان فيها عائله عائله
اسرائيليه ايضا ولكن اصيبت السياره وعند
فرار مطلقين نار ايضا اطلقوا النار على
سياره ثالثه قبل ان يشتبكوا ايضا مع قوات
امنيه اسرائيليه
باطلاق النار ثم قاموا باحراق السياره
التي استعملوها في العمليه وبعدها لجاوا
الى يا ريحه والحديث عن تحديدا عن مخيم
عقبه جبر وبالتالي هناك حشودات عسكريه
كبيره حول المدينه اغلاق المدينه بشكل
كامل هناك عمليات تفتيش تقوم بها قوات
الاسرائيليه نعم طيب عبد الحفيظ هل يخشى
من تكرار سيناريو حواره يعني هناك في في
اريحا اذا كان يعني هجوم من القوات
الاسرائيليه او من المستوطنين كما حدث في
حوار بالامس
صهيب هذا السيناريو متدحرج ومتكرر يوميا
يعني نحن حاولنا الذهاب الى مدينه اريحا
وكان من الصعب جدا نحن الان نقف قباله
مستوطنه هناك حشودات عسكريه خلفنا وهناك
خشيه ايضا من ان يقوم المستوطنون بالقاء
الحجاره هناك تحطيم مركبات جنوب مدينه
نابلس هناك اعتداء على العديد من الاملاك
الفلسطينيه تحديدا في مدينه الخليل وغيرها
وبالتالي الليل مخيف جدا اصبح بالنسبه
للفلسطنين من عمليات انتقام اسرائيليه
سواء مثل التي حدثت البارحه قد تحدث خلال
الايام القادمه على ذكر حواره كيف هو
وضعها الان يعني بعد ليله امس يعني كان
هناك
العديد من الاحداث واحراق السيارات
والمنازل والاعتداء على الفلسطينيين كيف
هو وضع حوار اليوم
ما زالت تحت اغلاق عسكري كبير ما زالت
القوات الاسرائيليه تنتشر بكثافه في محيط
البلده اليوم كان هناك مواجهات بين
المستوطنين وبين اهل البلد المدارس لليوم
يعني يوم غدا ايضا ستغلق بعد ان اغلقت هذا
اليوم وزاره التربيه والتعليم تخشى على
حياتها الطلاب من هجمات المستوطنين
وبالتالي ما زالت البلده مغلقه وما زالت
عمليات مصادره كاميرات المراقبه بحثا عن
منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار الذي قتل مستوطنين
في البلده يوم امس عبد الحفيظ جعوان كنت
معنا من رام الله
[موسيقى]
في العراق خرج مئات المحتجين الى الشوارع
للتعبير عن معارضتهم لمشروع قانون
الانتخابات الذي من شانه تقليص عدد
الدوائر الانتخابيه في البلاد حيث شهدت
شوارع بغداد تواجدا مكثفه للقوات الامن
حول مبنى البرلمان وتم اغلاق جسر
الجمهوريه المؤدي الى المناطق الحكوميه
بالمنطقه الخضراء هذا ويسعى نواب مستقلون
وقوى سياسيه مدنيه ومنظمات غير حكوميه الى
الدعم لابقاء قانون الدوائر المتعدده الذي
جرت وفقه انتخابات اكتوبر 2021
[موسيقى]
قالت الامم المتحده ان المبعوثه الليبيه
سيطلق مبادره تهدف الى تمكين الانتخابات
التشريعيه والرئاسيه هذا العام وسيشكل
لجنه توجيهيه رفيعه المستوى وقال المبعوث
عبد الله بطيلي ان الاليه ستجمع بين
ممثلين المؤسسات السياسيه والشخصيات
السياسيه الرئيسيه وزعماء القبائل ومنظمات
المجتمع المدني والمسؤولين الامنيين
والجماعات الاخرى ذات الصرح
[موسيقى]
في السودان اعلن والي غرب كردفان حاله
الطوارئ بكافه انحاء الولايه السودانيه
ومناطق البترول بها اعتبارا من اليوم
ولمده شهر قابل للتجديد وذكرت وكاله انباء
السودان ان الاعلان جاء وفقا لتوجيهات
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح
البرهان وسيتم تنفيذه عبر القوات المشتركه
بجانب تشكيل محكمه خاصه بواسطه السلطه
القضائيه والنيابه العامه هذا وتشهد ولايه
غرب كردفان هجمات متكرره على ابار البترول
والمنشاه النفطيه منذ اكثر من عام من قبل
بعض المجتمعات المحليه بالولايه لتنفيذ
بعض المطالب
صرح عضو مجلس سياده السوداني السابق محمد
الفكي سليمان عن انعقاد اجتماع مرتقب بين
القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
لمناقشه سير العمليه السياسيه
السلطه المدنيه يجب ان تستعد وباسرع درجه
لانه ما عاده البلاد تحتمل هل الناس
الموجودين في الاتفاق الاطار الكافيين ده
عدد كبير جدا من الناس كافي لانه يؤمن هذا
الانتقال الضموراتي حتى لو هذه القاعده
غير كافيه ملولح يوسع هذه القاعده نحن
بندير في هذا الحوار حاليا داخل قوه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الاطاري وفي طلبات
كثيره قدامنا اذا حتى لو تم توسيع هذا
الاتفاق الاطاري سوف يتم توسيعه بشروط
الثوره وليس بشروط اخرى ويجب ان يكون هذا
واضحا للجميع
[موسيقى]
نبقى في السودان حيث استجوبت السلطات
السودانيه 36 روسيا بين شهرين يناير
وفبراير على خلفيه الاشتباه بتهريبهم
للذهب وتقويد اقتصاد البلاد حسبما افادت
وكاله
قالت ان الروس المشتبه بهم هم موظفون في
مؤسسه التي اصبحت شركه التعدين المحليه
مالكه لها في عام 2021 عندما اشترت شركه
التعدين المحليه شركه لاستخراج الذهب تقع
بالقرب من مدينه عقبره كانت تملكها شركه
وذلك مقابل 1.8 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
قالت الحكومه الكنديه انها ستفرض عقوبات
على 12 من كبار المسؤولين في الحرس الثوري
الايراني بسبب ما ارتكبوه من انتهاكات
جسيمه ومنهجيه لحقوق الانسان وستشمل
العقوبات الكنديه قوات الامن الايرانيه
واقلت وزاره الخارجيه الكنديه في بيان ان
من بين المسؤولين المستهدفين محافظ اقليم
كردستان اسماعيل زرعي كوشه ومرتضى ميرا
اغاي قائد قوات البسيج في سنندج باقليم
كردستان الايراني
دعوات لتظاهرات جديده تعلو في ايران
والمعلمون يساندون العمال في احتجاجاتهم
لرفع اجورهم ومستحقاتهم ادعوات هذه تتزامن
مع تسجيل العمله المحليه الايرانيه مزيدا
من الانخفاض في قيمتها الشرائيه وتفاقم
الغلاء في ايران فيما اعلن المجلس
التنسيقي للمنظمات النقابيه للمعلمين في
البلاد دعمه لدعوه المتقاعدين اقامه
تجمعات احتجاجيه غدا وكانت عده مدن شهدت
احتجاجات عماليه ونقابيه مندده بتدهور
الوضع الاقتصادي وسط تاخر الرواتب
والزيادات التي وعدوا بها منذ اشهر هذا
ونظم متقاعدو شركه اصفهان للاتصالات مسيره
احتجاجيه للمطالبه بتطبيق لائحه الرعايه
الاجتماعيه لعام 2000 واحتجاجا على
مشاكلهم المعيشيه من خلال ترديد شعارات
مناوئه للحكومه
[موسيقى]
تعهد مكتب الامم المتحده للتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه بتقديم مبلغ 1.2 مليار دولار
كمساعده لليمن والتي تبلغ بكملها 4.3
مليار دولار وقال منسق شئون لغثه في اليمن
مارتن جريفيث ان مجمل التعهدات تبلغ واحد
وثلاثين تعهدا املا ان يصل المبلغ الى
مليار دولار بحلول نهايه الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
لا تزال تركيا تحت خطر الزلازل فاليوم ضرب
زلزال جديد بقوه 5.7 درجه على مقياس ريختر
وقع على عمق سبعه كيلومترات شرقي تركيا
بدورها افادت اداره الكوارث التركيه في
بيان بان الزلزال كان مركزه مقاطعه ملاطيا
واوضحت ان الزلزال الجديد تسبب في انهيار
22 مبنى ودخول 70 شخصا الى المستشفيات
مؤكده مقتل اثنين وبعد وقوع الزلزال
الجديد اظهرت مقاطع فيديو تداولتها مواقع
التواصل مشاهدا لمبان باتت ركاما على
الارض في ثوان وسط ذهول وصدمه من قبل
الحاضرين كما وثق احد السكان من شرفته
صورا لانهيار مباني في المدينه والدخان
الابيض يغطي المنطقه شاهدوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كم هي كثيره الماسي التي طفت بعد الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
فجرت السادسه من فبراير الحليب وكثيره هي
ايضا الصور التي وثقت تلك الكارثه التي
حصلت نحو 50 الف قتيل فضلا عن مفقودين تحت
الانقاب الا ان الاثر الذي تركته هذه
الصوره مشاهدينا صوره التركي مسعود هنتشر
ذلك الاب المكلوم الذي جلس فوق الركام
ممسكا يد ابنته المتوفاه تحت الانقاب تكاد
لا تمحى من ذاكره الملايين حول العالم لكن
هذا الرجل المحطم مشاهدينا لقى حمله تضامن
واسعه بعد ان تصدرت صورته وسائل الاعلام
حول العالم وشركها الملايين على مواقع
التواصل وبعد نحو ثلاثه اسابيع من الماساه
غادر هانشر وهو والد لاربعه اطفال غادر
بلدته كرمان مراش ليستقر في انقره حيث قدم
رجل اعمال من العاصمه مسكنا له ولاسرته
وعرض تعيينهم موظفا اداريا في القناه
التلفزيونيه التي يملكها
هذا وطلب رئيس تركيا الصفح من شعبه بسبب
الاستجابه المتاخره لكارثه الزلزال في
البلاد جاء ذلك خلال تفقده ولايه اديمان
وهي احدى الولايات المتضرره
بعد الزلزال المدمر كان هناك طقس بارد
وصعب جدا في الايام الاولى ربما لم نتمكن
من العمل كما كان يلزم بسبب صعوبه الظروف
لذلك اتمنى منكم المسامحه ونحن الان على
يقين باننا سنقوم بكل ما يلزم من اجل
مواجهه هذه التحديات
شاهدين في خبر عاجل ورد قبل قليل الخارجيه
المصريه اكدت ان لقاء الوزير سامح شكري مع
رئيس نظام السوري بشار الاسد في دمشق لم
يتطرق لعوده سوريا اذا الى الجامعه
العربيه وفي ملف العلاقات بين القاهره
وانقره تحدثت مصادر العربيه عن ان القاهره
تجهز لزياره مرتقبه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الى مصر في النصف الثاني من العام
كما اشرت المصادر المصريه الى انه تم
تحديد مباحثات بين مصر وتركيا في شهر
ابريل المقبل لرفع التمثيل الدبلوماسي بين
القاهره وانقره هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه
التركي
انه من المحتمل ان يعقد اجتماع بين
الرئيسين التركي رجب طيب اردوغان والرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي خلال الفتره
المقبله واثناء لقاء مع نظيره المصري سامح
شكري في ميناء مرسين اكد الوزير التركي ان
انقره ستعمل على نقل العلاقات مع القاهره
الى مستوى اعلى
نقوم بفتح صفحات جديده مع مصر وسنعمل على
نقل العلاقات مع القاهره الى مستوى اعلى
في الاونه الاخيره كانت هناك مباحثات بين
الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس السيسي وتب حثت
اليوم مع سامح شكري بشان الخطوات التي
علينا اتخاذها لتطوير العلاقات بين بلدينا
وتطور العلاقات التركيه المصريه سيؤثر
ايجابا على المنطقه باكملها من جانبه قال
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري انه يحمل
رساله تضامن الى تركيا بعد الزلزال الذي
ضرب البلاد
ان محمد
رساله
تضامن ومؤازره ومواساه الى الشعب التركي
صديق
على مستوى القياده
والحكومه والشعب المصري
لهذا المصاب وهذه الكارثه التي
تالمنا جميعا
لوقعها
نعمل بكل ما لدينا من جهد لمؤازره اخواتنا
واخواتنا في
تركيا
لتجاوز هذه المحنه
هذا واستقبل رئيس النظام السوري بشار
الاسد وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري في
دمشق في زياره هي الاولى من نوعها منذ
سنوات من اجل نقل رساله تضامن من مصر مع
الدولتين وشعبيهما هذا وقال شكري في مؤتمر
صحفي مع نظيره السوري ان مصر ستستمر في
التواصل لدعم الجهد الانساني في سوريا
مضيفا بان القاهره على استعداد لتوفير كل
الدعم الانساني للسوريين
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بريطانيا تتوصل
الاتفاق مع الاتحاد الاوروبي حول ايرلندا
الشماليه ضمن اتفاق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعترضوا في الصين بشده
على الفرضيه التي طرحتها وزاره الطاقه
الامريكيه والتي تفيد بان كوفيد 19 تسرب
اثر حادث عربي من مختبر صيني واشدد
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه على
انه يجب على واشنطن التوقف عن تشويه سمعه
بيكين وعن تاسيس الابحاث المتعلقه بمنشا
الفيروس
[موسيقى]
وبعد اكثر من عام على المفاوضات صارت
بريطانيا على سكه اتمام الاتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لمحاوله الحد من مشكلات
سياسيه وتجاريه في ايرلندا الشماليه ويبدو
انها نجحت المشكلات هذه المشاهدين تسبب
بها اتفاق خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهو المبرم في عام 2020
المفاوضات شهدت التعثر مرارا بسبب الخلاف
بين لندن وبروكسيل حول تعديل جزء من
الاتفاق وفي اطار وقعت بريطانيا اتفاقا مع
بروكسل معروف باسم بروتوكول ايرلندا
الشماليه لتفادي نقاط التفتيش المثيره
للاحتقان السياسيه على امتداد الحدود
البريه مع ايرلندا العضو بالاتحاد
الاوروبي ماذا يعني ذلك بموجب البروتوكول
نشات قيود تمنع نقل بعض البضائع من
بريطانيا لانه ابقى ايرلندا الشماليه في
السوق الاوروبيه الموحده فاليوم وبعد لقاء
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه اكد رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ان الاتفاق مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي يحمي سياده ايرلندا الشماليه
ويمنع وضع حدود بين ايرلندا الشماليه
وجمهوريه ايرلندا وفيما يخص العلاقات مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي اشار سونات الى ان
بريطانيا فتحت صفحه جديده في العلاقات مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي وانه سيتم تطبيق قانون
الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا الشماليه
لتفادي وضع حدود في الجزيره
[موسيقى]
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي يحمي سياده ايرلندا
الشماليه ويمنع وضع حدود بين ايرلندا
الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا بما يؤول الى
ازاله كل عقبات نقل البضائع التجاريه بين
ايرلندا الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا كما
نود الاشاره الى انه سيتم تطبيق قانون
الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا الشماليه
لتفادي وضع حدود في الجزيره وازاله اي
حدود بحريه في البحر الايرلندي بشان
العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي بريطانيا
فتحت صفحه جديده في العلاقات معه
اذا نتحدث عن مشكله ايرلندا الشماليه
وبريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي دعونا
مشاهدينا نتحدث عن جذور المشكله فرغم
جغرافيه ايرلندا الشماليه الصغيره
مشاهدينا كما نشاهد في الخريطه فان
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لها تجعل منها حجره
اساس في مستقبل العلاقات الاوروبيه
البريطانيه من جهه والبريطانيه الامريكيه
من جهه اخرى ويعتبر ملف ايرلندا الشماليه
من اعقد الملفات في كل مفاوضات الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع بريطانيا بعد لما له من حموله
سياسيه وتاريخيه خطيره تهدد بتفجير الوضع
في الجزيره الايرلنديه من جديد فما الازمه
التي تعيشها ايرلندا الشماليه منذ فبراير
العام الماضي قرر الحزب الوحدوي
الديمقراطي اسقاط السلطه التنفيذيه التي
يقودها كاحتجاج على صيغه ما يعرف
بالبروتوكول الخاص بايرلندا الشماليه الذي
يحدد وضعيه الاخيره بعد خروج المملكه
المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد ذلك تم
تنظيم انتخابات جديده منحت الصداره هذه
المره لحزب شين فين الانفصالي الذي يوصف
بانه الذراع السياسي للجيش الجمهوري
الايرلندي الا ان الازمه السياسيه ظلت
مستمره دون اي حل اما السبب في استمرار
الازمه السياسيه فيعود الى ان النظام
السياسي الذي يعتمد على التوازن بين مؤيدي
الانفصال عن بريطانيا ومؤيدي الوحده بحيث
يحتفظ الحزب الخاسر بحق تعيين نائب لرئيس
حكومه الحزب الفائز وهذا يطرح سؤال لماذا
انسحب الوحدويون اذا من كل اجهزه الدوله
الاجابه انه بسبب البروتوكول الخاص
بالبلاد والمتفق عليه بين لندن والبروكسيل
حيث يرون انه يخدم الانفصاليين ولا يراعي
مطالبهم
اذا لماذا يثير البروتوكول الخاص بايرلندا
كل هذا الجدل الجدل سببه نقاط التفتيش
والجمارك بين بريطانيا وايرلندا والتي
تريد اي الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تطبق عليها
المعايير الاوروبيه وهو مبدا يرفضه
الوحدوي
[موسيقى]
اجتاحت سلسله من الاعاصير كلاهما وكانساس
في وقت مبكر تاركه طريقا من الهياكل
المدمره والمركبات المقلوبه كما تسببت في
اصابه العشرات وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي
عن عشره الالاف من المنازل والشركات حيث
افادت الشرطه في نورمان بولاهما ان اثنى
عشر شخصا نقلوا الى المستشفيات بعد تعرضهم
لاصابات جراء العواصف التي اجتاحت المسيح
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
ل عن تقرير حكومي واشنطن ترك الطائرات
وصواريخ ومعدات بقيمه سبعه مليار دولار
بيد طالبان
اوكرانيا تتوقع تصعيدا عسكريا خلال الاشهر
الثلاثه المقبله لحسم الحرب والكرملين
يؤكد ان الحل السلمي ليس الان
[تصفيق]
تحذيرات غربيه من تفجر الوضع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وسط دعوات لجميع الاطراف
للتهدئه
[موسيقى]
ترفض بشده تقارير الامريكيه بان فيروس
كورونا تسرب اثراء حادث عربي من مختبر
صيني
[موسيقى]
شكرا على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء